good morning everyone and welcome
to this program this is an introduction
to
a program that is starting today called
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and this program is going to be hosted
at the university of ghana
but in general we'll talk about how
bioinformatics can be used in the
context
of infectious diseases and the
host pathogen interaction so those of
you that have not yet registered to the
program
you'll see an overview of how you can
complete your registration
but you will also be able to learn about
general application
of bioinformatics to the study of
viruses
uh micro and other microorganisms that
cause
human disease and we're excited that all
of you are joining
hopefully i will be able to answer most
of your
questions and if not i will also point
you to a number of resources that we
have available
for all of you that are joining today
so let's start by talking about briefly
this program
bioinformatics for infectious disease is
a program
that is specifically designed for those
interested
in conducting research using
bioinformatics
tools so we'll talk about where to find
data
how to analyze such data what to
do with your analysis results in terms
of biological interpretation
and our main objective here is to
provide a
support system for those of you
interested in leveraging bioinformatics
analysis tools
to really get to a place where you can
get a publication or maybe a poster
presentation and you're making progress
in terms of research outcomes so that's
the main objective
uh what we'll do today is we'll review
uh all of these different resources that
will be included
we'll also take a look at a number of
different sessions that are going to be
coming up so that you're aware of
the schedule and how things are going to
be organized and what's the expectation
what are some of the dates
and hopefully we'll be able to answer
any questions that you have
both about the program itself and about
the outcomes how to get to those
outcomes that we'll talk about now i'm
going to be guiding this particular
session but i want to mention that this
program first of all
the oversight and the development of the
resources and tools
are going to be overseen by the
university of haifa
tower bioinformatics research center so
this research center
is a research center focused on
bioinformatics tools and
algorithms they specialize in developing
novel algorithms that we will be
reviewing and using during the sessions
that we have
uh it is uh guided by dr lena brodsky
and dr alfred tauber
both of them with extensive research
experience and collaborations
but also we have a dedicated team that
is supporting our training activities
helping with all of the technical
resources that we have
and maintain a whole community of
thousands of users from around the world
that are learning bioinformatics and
applying those to a variety of different
topics so
at the end of this session you will be
able to learn about some of the
additional programs that we are
launching um in february that include
uh programs on metagenomics genomics
different types of applications of those
as well and in different locations for
example
in nigeria in louisiana in the us
and in india so how do these sessions
work i'm sure that most of you are
already familiar with how we kind of
operate
we have a number of kind of resources
that work together
to make these sessions effective first
of all
we have our interactive sessions which
is something that you'll experience
today hopefully it is interactive in the
sense that it's not just going to be me
speaking but we'll also hear from some
of you
and learn about your background and your
interests
but also we have a number of guided
materials that you can go through
to learn about different types of data
different tools for analysis
and how to conduct a research study
using
bioinformatics analysis tools and so
we'll review a little bit of how these
guided materials are organized and how
we can make those
into a part of a session in other words
we will show you how the activity of
your progress through those asynchronous
resources is tracked
and how do we use it to make sure that
we address the topics that everybody
has questions about or is struggling
with
the final one are the practical
assignments so these practical
assignments
are really an introduction to research
tools and
bioinformatics is a comprehensive
name of a whole field of research where
we use databases analytical tools
visualization of data
interpretation of data right so there
are many components to bioinformatics so
these practical assignments are designed
to introduce you
in to some cloud-based big data analysis
tools but also
some practical skills how to manage your
data how to effectively
visualize annotate and work with your
data
so it's going to include some coding
some big data analysis tools
and hopefully i'll clarify this in just
a few more minutes
now the sessions are guided by a number
of
people and so these are your main
contacts
uh i'm going to introduce all of us now
so that you're familiar with our team
and then i'll ask you a few questions
about you
so that we can also get to know you so
first of all you probably are already
familiar with uh beeps
biswas she's our community manager and
responsible for logistics and accounts
and you'll be getting a lot of emails
from her so as this program starts
it's important for you to make sure that
you have her email address saved in your
contacts which is
marketing at pine dot bio this is an
important contact because she will be
sending you
a lot of information about recordings of
the sessions that we complete
information about upcoming sessions as
well as any assignments and additional
resources that you should have access to
and so if you have any questions about
your login
about your account about how to use
something she would be
the person who can direct your info your
questions to the right person
or answer them herself the second person
on our team
is dr harpreet kaur she has a phd in
bioinformatics and specialized in
genomics specifically in cancer but she
is
very well versed in all of the methods
of analysis that we have
on the t by info platform so for any
technical assistance
questions about methods how to run those
methods
issues with your input data or output
data
please also add her into your contacts
her email is
support pine dot bio thank you pizza you
can find those email addresses
in the chat box dr mahit mazumdar
is our project mentor he will help you
work with available data on public
domain
repositories identify that data make
sure that you understand how that data
has been generated
and help you translate your idea about
how to research that particular
data set into a research question so you
can also
find him on his email which is mohit
pine dot bio so he will be helping you
and guiding you for the different
projects that you
have already maybe thought of or you're
starting to think about
and develop throughout this program my
name is elia brodsky
so i'm going to be helping by conducting
some of the live
sessions and also helping you by linking
you
to the right resources that we have on
our platforms on the different
websites that we operate and also i
could help
by providing some feedback on the
research projects
as they develop or any other technical
questions that you might have
a lot of times i will leverage our
collaborators at the tower
bioinformatics research center
and getting you good information from
them to answer
any scientific questions that you might
have so let me tell you a little bit
more about our team
what is their background and what do
they really specialize in
dr mohit mazumdar has over 10 years of
experience has
got his phd in bioinformatics or chemo
informatics
primarily he now works with a number of
faculty
and university contacts as well as
industry contacts that we have
but his phd was focused on developing a
method to identify and predict
calcium binding sites and study binding
affinity
with calcium so he had to really master
data mining and become proficient at
predictive modeling
so he would be especially helpful once
you get to
one of the sessions where we will
discuss
structures how proteins interact with
different ligands how proteins interact
with other proteins
how do we deal with structural biology
questions
even though he's also familiar with the
number of other applications of
bioinformatics that we will cover
like analysis of ngs data
now as i mentioned uh uh dr harpridka or
um she has her phd in
uh focused on prognosis of liver cancer
identifying biomarkers and primarily her
expertise
is with genomic and transcriptomic data
so you'll find her expertise primarily
on how to analyze
big data how to apply machine learning
to
gene expression data genomic data how to
integrate data through multi-omics
integration methods and how to develop a
sense
of what are the specific features in
that data that are most
insightful that are most important for
our ability to differentiate between
different
disease stages or disease conditions
or maybe different types of population
representatives
so that is her background now
i told you a little bit about our team i
would like now to also
ask you about your background so i'm
going to launch
a poll uh this poll will will
ask you the following question so first
of all
uh sorry one second
that should be later so first of all
uh what country are you from
uh so we have a number of countries that
we expected people to
be from including ghana nigeria
india usa or maybe other so
if your answer is other then please
put in the answer into the chat box uh
beeps do you see the poll is the poll
live now
yes yeah it's live now okay
so please answer the question number one
is which country are you from
um now the second question is about the
city
which city are you from uh we
also anticipated a couple of cities we
don't know exactly where you're from but
uh lagos kolkata accra in ghana or
delhi uh or new orleans boston
or maybe other so please uh you can
if you don't see i don't see any answers
right now in the poll yet but
uh please uh respond in the poll
if it's other just click on other and
then you'll be able to
put in the response there
okay university so again
this program is primarily hosted
by the university of ghana
and the people from that university we
have that answer
in the poll university of ghana
louisiana state university
haifa university or other so please put
your responses again
in the poll number four
is about your degree so your degree
could be
bachelor's master's phd or
other and
then another couple of questions
research interest
so your interest could be in virology
microbiology genomics bioinformatics
or other and then
what is your background your background
could be
researcher so the background the
background could be
researcher student faculty
industry or other so again this is a
poll
you should be able to see the poll and
so please add your information
from answering the questions in the poll
i'll give you a couple
of moments here to answer all of these
questions i know that it's a lot but
it's a good way
to get to know everyone and really
understand
our audience a little bit better
okay great so what we're seeing is we
have about over
50 percent of the participants here are
currently researchers and so that's
great to know
um and other um about
seven to ten percent or faculty so
that's great
um now i'll leave this poll on
for now but i'll continue with my slides
and the primary thing that i wanted to
get to is that we have
[Music]
this free course called introduction to
bioinformatics
and the reason why we start with this
course
one of the reasons is because it is a
course where we
have a survey in the survey a lot of the
same information is being asked
and thank you beeps for putting that in
the chat box so let me
show you how to access this course
uh please go with me to edu dot
t bio dot info so this is the link
okay thank you pizza and let me know
once you're there
okay you can put yes or i'm there
or number one
and yes just again about the poll
answers
if you could please use the poll to
answer the question
so that way we'll have a structured data
set at the end and we can
review the data together with our
collaborators thank you
right
okay thank you so if you're here this is
a website
where we store a lot of our asynchronous
materials
including uh some of the important
information for this program itself
so if you don't have an account already
you need to create an account
if you are from the university of ghana
and you have registered for the program
through university of ghana
your account information should have
been sent out to you so please use that
use that information to sign in and i'll
just briefly show you once you're here
you can go to courses and this is the
course that i'm asking you to take a
look at
it's called introduction to
bioinformatics and this is
a course that on one hand is a course
designed for beginners maybe
you're thinking i am already a
researcher or a faculty i know a lot
about bioinformatics and
we of course understand that we're not
saying that this is going to be some
revolutionary course but it's a free
resource
and one of the important things in this
course is that it has an intro survey
in this intro survey we collect
information about the users
primarily to identify major trends and
interests of the people
that are joining our program so as a
part of this
infectious disease program you will see
some of this information that we already
collected in the poll
but you're welcome to submit that
information again because we're also
interested in your bioinformatics
experience in your general background
why you want to learn bioinformatics or
maybe
already learning bioinformatics what
would you expect to take away from these
courses
and if there's anything else that you
would like to share for example
some specific type of interest that you
have and we haven't
mentioned it in the survey you can ask
that or you can answer that right there
okay so again please take a look at this
course
and we hope to learn more about all of
the participants here
now the other thing that you will notice
is that we have
in this portal a way to
really tie in all of the progress that
we are going to be doing in this program
into your
profile so i'm giving here an example of
a profile
somebody that has previously completed
or bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
and i want to mention that it's really
an impactful
part of completing your profile to make
sure
that your certification is up to date in
other words when you complete
a course you will get an automatically
generated certificate
that certificate could be shared on
social media it could be used for other
purposes
but it's important that your full name
the way that you would like it to be uh
on your certificate
is spelled out right here right so for
example this is going to be your
username once you sign up
but this is going to be your full name
now it's also interesting for us to know
if you're a faculty
or you're a part of a company or
something like that that you add that
information right here
and we anticipate many of you to have a
social media profile
on facebook on linkedin on other
platforms so please
add that information there as well and
beeps also posted
a link in the chat box on how to
complete your
profile so here we would like to
ask all of you to take some time maybe
after the session
add that information in there now once
you have completed your registration for
the program
you will also see a badge and this badge
is an
indication that you're a part of the
program and so for the duration of that
program
this badge is going to be available
after you complete the program you will
get a certificate
and i will show you in your profile
where you will see all of that
information including
your certificate of course completion
your certificate of program completion
and as you prepare a project of your own
also your project is going to be added
there as well
now once you have made your
profile on the tb is platform we also
invite you to join our social media
groups and these groups are not just for
us to
you know share updates this is an
important place where we share
uh different job openings so if you're
looking for a career in bioinformatics
there's a lot of
positions open there are a lot of
collaborative projects as well
so you will find information about
different resources
important updates about our programs but
also other programs and other resources
that are out there
and we hope that you can join these
programs again beeps have posted
the social media links in the chat box
so you can find those there
please do connect with us so you will
find uh
myself uh dr mizunder dr kaor
biepsa and everybody else that works for
a company
listed in those groups as well so we
hope to connect with you on social media
stay in touch and hopefully share
updates about this program and others
as you join
okay so let's talk about bioinformatics
for
infectious diseases so again this is a
program that is intended
to support research projects through
training
so we're going to do some training we're
going to do some exercises
and to explain how these exercises are
organized in this session i will give
you a sense
of what those exercises will be and how
to find
project examples that illustrate the
impact
of these different types of analysis
techniques
so first of all we'll talk about
sequence variation
and alignment so you're probably
familiar with
methods of aligning two sequences which
is called pairwise alignment
or multiple sequences msa
but we'll take a look at some of the
importance of
different types of variants and
different types of
mutations that cause changes in the
amino acids
maybe that cause stop codons to appear
and we'll think about how to find
this important variation especially when
we deal with
complex sequencing so we'll talk about
sequences of
individual genes or regions as well as
full genomes and we'll talk about the
consequence of that
now another part of sequence alignment
is the reconstruction of the
evolutionary tree so we'll talk a little
bit about
phylogenetic analysis and how these
sequences
can inform us about the molecular clock
and how they could have originated from
a common ancestor
and how do we piece that information
together we'll talk about how to
map such genomic variation onto protein
structure and explore
the structure changes using 3d
representation
of these proteins produced by cryoam
microscopy we'll talk about also
transcriptomic analysis of host response
so we'll take a look at how do we
analyze the impact
that is uh for example in the context of
a disease
on the host and what are some of those
genes that are differentially expressed
how do we map that onto
a pathway how do we interpret the
analysis results
but before we jump into these specific
topics let's talk
a little bit about infectious and
non-infectious diseases
so an infection is the invasion
of an organism's body tissues by
disease-causing agents
their multiplication or replication and
the reaction of host tissues to the
infectious agent
and the toxins that they produce so an
infectious disease
is also primarily known as transmissible
disease or communicable disease
which is an illness resulting from an
infection so
one of the major components of
infectious diseases
as opposed to non-infectious diseases is
that
one they are caused by a pathogen and
two that they are shared
from multiple between multiple people or
between multiple hosts
non-infectious diseases are not caused
by a pathogen
cannot be shared from one person to
another and are caused by
other factors such as environment
nutritional deficiencies lifestyle
choices or genetic inheritance
so because we are separating these
bioinformatics programs
into different categories this is one of
the reasons why we want to focus
specifically on infectious diseases
because the topics that we will
go over include different pathogens
and you can see some of the examples
here like flu hiv
malaria and we'll talk about the impact
on the host right
you can see that right here for example
sickle cell disease
or we can talk about how the reaction to
different toxin happens
so what are some of the important things
that we will discuss in the context of
the program
we'll talk about replication and or
colonization so we'll talk about how
does that process happen
we'll talk about the result to the host
cells for example cell
death how does that happen as a result
of what
and the release of toxins and how the
impact of cell death
and the release of toxins has an impact
on
organ function interference and damage
to interference with that normal
function
now another important part that we'll
talk about is
the response right and so our bodies
have
er these uh response mechanisms
that include different ways that our
body deals with
these intruders and we'll talk about how
the immune system has several different
types of responses
these responses can be uh trained
or induced and that is really the basis
for many of the interventions that we
are going to look at and we're going to
look at how those interventions work
in different patients or in different
examples
and we'll also take a look at how those
responses could be induced
and what are some examples of such
interventions
so as you know vaccines um are
one of the first types of interventions
that has been introduced and it has been
introduced
as far as back as the earth early 1800s
and so you know it's been a long time
since the concept
of vaccination has been introduced but
as you can see in this chart
below that is not the only way
that disease burden has been reduced
in fact we can see that other types of
interventions for example
we can see antibacterial
penicillin we can see here
the vaccine that was introduced and
we also see other types of interventions
for example
continuous municipal use of chlorine in
water in the united
states right so in the context of the
history of
dealing with infectious diseases there
have been major
progress and major successes at the same
time
there now we know that that has not been
the solution to everything that is out
there so in fact
with covid19 we are reminded once again
of how morbid this infectious disease
as a pandemic can be even with all of
the tools that we have at our disposal
so while the history of dealing with
infectious diseases
is full of successes that we can
celebrate we can also
be reminded about the continuous need to
study
microorganisms and infectious diseases
develop
novel ways to resolve them but
also develop technologies that help us
understand
how infectious diseases are uh
causing disease and where do they come
from where they originate from
so one of the ways that we will look at
this we will see that uh while
in the beginning one of the primary
tools that we had to understand
microorganisms was the microscope
but today we have additional types of
information
like genomic sequencing that really
helps us
address the impact of infectious
diseases
understand virulence of these different
pathogens understand their protein
expression
understand how to diagnose them more
precisely
insights into the molecular mechanisms
that they
interact with the host and with the
vectors and
also understand how how do they evolve
how do they change from a pathogen that
might not cause such a harmful
effect to a pathogen that could be very
deadly so what are
the processes as well as what are the
specific manifestations
of those processes so we'll take a look
at these different technologies
like sequencing and we'll start seeing
how do we apply those in the context of
specific project
examples so one can also think about
differences in viral responses
we can think about different strains we
can
think about different types of responses
and a lot of that information could be
captured
from sequencing but of course sequencing
could be of many different types
and the important part for us is we will
take a look at how
from sequence data we can start looking
at
structural analysis we can look at gene
expression studies
and as the data becomes available
determine
patterns that could be impactful for our
detailed understanding of protein
protein interaction
as well as single cell level response to
these different pathogens
and how do we piece all that data
together
so to really take a look at such a
diverse
range of topics we have prepared a
number of
different examples and in those examples
we'll take a look at
viral genomics and evolution we will
take a look at
microbiome and the infection through the
microbiome
we'll also take a look at different
examples of immune response biomarkers
to understand how this process happens
now before we go on i wanted to make
sure that i
do pauses as i said the intent of these
sessions
is to create a uh an interaction
right and not only kind of a lecture so
i'm really looking forward to
learning more about your interests and
to understand
whether some of these topics that we
raise i'm going to be at
pausing and asking if you have any
questions
now as we go through and you have again
non-technical questions you can post
them in the chat
and beeps should be able to respond to
those directly
if you do have questions about the
topics that i go through in the slides
this would be the opportunity to hear
what your questions might be
so again if you have any questions
right now you can put those in the chat
and in the meantime
i am going to share the results of uh
the poll beep say can you see the
results of the poll
uh yes celia i can see the results of
the poll
so for the first question which is what
country are you from so we have
30 percent of attending participants who
are from ghana
seven person participants are from
nigeria
india has about 26 percent attendance
and we have two person from the us as
well and 36 percent of participants
which is the largest
number are from other countries and some
of those countries which are mentioned
in the chat box were pakistan brazil
and a few other countries so
if you still want to add your country
you can or your
city or your department and name you can
again put that in the chat box if you
have not answered
uh going to the second question what
city are you from
so we have 26 percent of participants
who are from
accra two person from lagos to person
from kolkata five percent from delhi
and there are 64 percent who are from
others
and which university are you currently
in so we have 28 person participants
today who are from the university of
ghana
and we have the rest of the participants
from different
universities around the world
and what what is your current degree
which is a fourth question
and we have 46 percentile
who are in a master's program which is
the highest number
then we have 30 percent phds
bachelor degree holders are 20 percent
and
5 percent are others while the research
interest is the highest in
bioinformatics which is 75 percent
followed by genomics which is 46 percent
followed by uh the same percentile of 26
percent in both biology and microbiology
while there are 23 percent who are
interested
in other research and
regarding the background which is the
last question
we have 46 percent who are researchers
joining us today
and this is the highest number while 38
percent are students we have 10 percent
faculty
and 3 percent industry while there are
also 3 percent
others so this is the poll result from
the session so far thank you elia
thank you i do also want to mention
uh that i see uh and maybe you could
put in the chat box again the links to
social media groups i see dorothea
obiri from the university of ghana
pratik
paul a student at
sam higginbottom university ali al
zaire biomedical informatics doesn't say
from where
is my uh ismaila adams
uh data scientist and researcher and
elio nye
maura so those are the people that have
joined the group and if you are still
not there
so please join uh the groups there on uh
social media
okay so let me address some of these
questions uh ahmad
giffary is asking about whole genome
sequence
it's mentioned that we can detect
mutations related to virulence
how are the researchers conclude their
findings from whole genome sequencing
into more
transmittable virus so i think here
you're really talking about
association between phenotype
and genotype so using whole genome
sequencing we can identify the mutations
by using other type of information for
example
rates of transmission or virulence
and those are going to be either
collected from the population like rates
of transmission or they could be
studied in the context of an experiment
so one of the things that we'll talk
about in our next session
is how this data is generated and we'll
see actually
how one of the examples will take data
from the ebola virus outbreak from 2014
to 2016
as you know it spread in the west africa
and it was
the first example where an uh epidemic
was also paralleled with almost
real-time sequencing efforts so there
was a lot of data that was coming from
different groups
and we'll see how in the context of that
epidemic it's a good case study because
it started and it ended right it's not
the
like the ongoing pandemic that we're
still kind of looking at
so what we are going to look at is how
to
find those associations between mutants
mutations and the phenotype but
the overall idea is that you can do
for example controlled studies where you
understand the mechanism
or you can find an association and that
association could be using
something like genome-wide association
study where you
translate your phenotypic information
into numeric data
and then there are methods to find that
using a regression model
um let me go to the next question a
qualmite
are all infectious diseases necessarily
pathogenic organisms
from my veterinary background i know a
couple of diseases such as canine
general tumor taci devil facial tumor
these are infections but not
caused by pathogens so again
there might be exceptions i
do not come from a veterinary background
and just kind of
talking about the general uh
descriptions uh but
you know definitely interested to learn
more and i'll look into that
and if you have any more clarification
about those
examples that you mentioned please put
those in the chat that that really
sounds fascinating
um okay the other question is
how can i identify the position of
different regions of the gene
in sequence if no information about the
exact position
from reference papers so i think that
has to do with
uh genomes that are not well annotated
so you don't have an
annotation and you want to identify
how does a gene sequence fall in the
context of the full genome perhaps
right maybe you can clarify the question
but
i think the approach would be to first
create an assembled genome so to
assemble
either the whole genome which could be
very difficult in some cases
or at least in context right so into
portions that are fairly large the way
it's done is using de bruyne graphs
you can find kind of in
short sequences of reads you can find
overlapping regions and connect them
together into longer sequences
and so depending on the length of the
read the coverage
uh other information that is available
you can probably piece together a fairly
good
portion and then try to map your
specific gene sequence onto that region
i think that that would be the general
approach
okay how to identify the viral genes in
an organism
great question we'll talk about that and
today i'll introduce one of the examples
where you can actually find
a pathogen from another in infectious
in cell lines that are using for that
are being used for biologics production
so
let's get to that in just a couple of
minutes
by the end of this program will we be
able to identify
parasite genotyping sequencing so
my hope is that yes my hope is that
very soon into the program you will be
able to
take gene sequencing information so
information from a sequencer
and understand what type of parasite
this is or what type of a genome
does it map to we'll take take a look at
a few examples where you can map onto
a database of viruses or you can
look at a database of bacteria so that
way you will be able to identify those
okay i'll take the last question how to
find snips
in exonic and intronic region okay
excellent question as we all know genes
are
can consist of exons and introns and so
if we have whole
genome sequencing which includes the
full sequence both
exons and introns we can map them onto
the reference and identify those snips
if we only have exon sequencing or
x-zone
sequencing then we cannot but i think in
general
you should be able to given the right
type of data
again thank you for all of these
questions i'll continue to
make pauses like this so if you have a
question
as we go through the slides please put
them in the chat
and i will try to address them as soon
as we get to a breaking point
all right let's talk about next
generation sequencing now again in our
next session we're going to talk a lot
more
about different types of sequencing and
how
that is used in different file formats
how those file formats could be
visualized and things like that today i
will give you a brief introduction
we have about 15 minutes to go through
the next set of slides
then i'll pause for a few more questions
and then i will pass it on to
uh and then i will show you how to
access different parts of
the resources that we have
okay so one of the things about
sequencing is that sequencing technology
can identify what are the specific
nucleotides
but the way the data is prepared
could be in many different ways and some
good examples
are targeted amplicon sequencing or
whole genome sequencing
so there are many different library
preparation techniques
that essentially mean that once the
genetic material the
biological material is collected and
dna or rna is extracted from that sample
that needs to go through several
additional steps and those steps could
determine
what are you in the end sequencing and
therefore how to analyze that data
so three major examples that we will
again look at
in much greater detail in our next
session are targeted sequencing
when a particular gene or even a region
of a gene
is amplified using pcr amplification
and then once you do the reading of that
sequence or the sequencing itself
you are really trying to make sure that
first of all you remove those sequences
that helped
exclude those particular regions from
the rest
and you are dealing with the impact of
pcr amplification
on the number of reads that you're
getting from different regions
then you can map it onto a reference
genome
or if you know exactly which regions
have been amplified
you can only map it onto those reference
sequences so we'll take a look of that
at that
many times this is done for example in
the context of the current pandemic
people want to ask the question are
there particular
novel mutations appearing in the spike
region right so they will amplify
only the spike protein or they can ask
the question
in wastewater or in blood samples of
patients
could we amplify just covid19 or source
code to
genome in another case if you're looking
at the microbiome you might want to ask
the question about the composition
of the microbiome you don't want to
survey any particular
individual representative of the
microbiome but you want to understand
how does the composition change
does this group of bacteria become more
prominent
or less prominent right and so then you
can amplify
the 16s ribosomal rna gene and that
would be
an example of amplicon sequencing for a
whole dna in rna sequencing
you could sequence all of the data that
comes from
let's say again a human blood sample but
you could suspect finding
specific bacteria or specific
viruses and typically you are likely to
find
things like hepatitis virus maybe
epstein-barr virus and other types of
viruses and i'll show you an example
today from maybe if we have time
so those are again important to
understand because when we find
data especially if we're dealing with
public repositories
we need to go through and understand
what was the method of preparing
such data before we try to analyze it
now the exciting part
is that there has been a tremendous
growth
of data in various repositories both
specific repositories like viral
repositories and databases
specific databases around different
types of diseases like malaria
or in general publicly available data on
the host response
vectors etc so i think it's an exciting
time for those that
know how to use bioinformatics because
what we need to understand is that
we should be able to find data on
practically
any pathogen that you're interested in
likely somebody has sequenced it
and so there should be some information
obviously that's not true
in a hundred percent of the cases but in
most of the times that i've interacted
with groups of
people learning about a particular
domain we were able to find
some publicly available data and that
gives us a head start right so you don't
have to
start in a vacuum you really have a
repository where you can find a lot of
information
to deal with different types of data
now as i mentioned one of the additional
aspects of that is that we have almost
real time
sequencing efforts that allow us to
sample
pandemics and epidemics and other types
of
communicable diseases almost in real
time
developing a sense of what is going on
and so
one of the first things to do is to
identify
what is the pathogen and so here you can
see
that typically one of the key aspects of
identification of the primary
mechanism or the primary pathogen is to
have a full genome
now it's not easy to make a full genome
if you just have short read sequences
available
so people typically rely on singer
sequencing
and long read sequencing to establish
how do the different pieces connect
together
after that is done you are typically
able to find
how individual reeds map onto that
reference genome so here you can see
one of the first genomes that was
published for source code too
uh it was essentially these little
lines here represent the individual
reads and those reads
were mapped onto the closest known
genome so you can see that this is beta
corona virus from wuhan
right and so once you have all of these
short reads
mapped onto some kind of a reference you
can now start asking the questions
what is the difference and so there
we'll take a look at
many different types of questions that
you can ask about the sequence
primarily around how is it different
and what is it that we are ex what are
we
biologically studying in this kind of
data
so one of the things that now we need to
turn to
are what are some of the analysis
methods that are available and again
let's go back to where we started
we talked about sequence variation and
primarily that's found through sequence
alignment but we'll see how
multiple types of answers could be
obtained from
alignment including what's called
reconstruction of evolution and
that could mean in the context of
multiple samples or even
an individual sample as we will take a
look
now the second question that you might
ask is once you've identified
a region of interest for example the
spike protein
how could you actually interpret the
impact of specific variants
on binding on maybe other structural
properties
of that particular protein because you
understand
its function and a way to study the
function
is to study the host response through
transcriptomic data analysis now in the
context of this program
we will be using the t-biome for
platform and
the reason why we are going to be using
this platform
is because it will provide you a number
of
tools that you can easily use without
any computational infrastructure
just in your browser for very large data
sets
and so because this is a research
program
all of you that join the program will
have access to
a personal research account and so that
means that you will be able to upload
data sets with hundreds of samples
analyze those
without requiring your own computational
infrastructure and so we hope that as a
result of that
you'll not only learn about how this
data is generated and what it can give
you
but you'll actually do a lot of that
practical uh work yourself
so let me show you um first of all
what this platform is all about so
let's go to server.tbio
info and please let me know once you are
there by putting
number one or yes or i'm there in the
chat box
and i'll give it just a couple of uh
minutes for everybody to get here
beeps if you could also share the demo
account details
okay so those of you that are a part of
the
infectious disease program you've
already completed your registration
you should have gotten an email with
your
account so if you do have your account
you should use that account you should
log in with your
email and a password that you were given
for all the rest that have not yet uh
registered and want to kind of try this
out you can use the demo account
that beeps is showing right here that
she has pasted in the chat box
okay so i see one two three four five
six so let's give it a moment maybe
until we have at least 10 people there
[Music]
okay
okay has anyone else logged in
all right great we have 10 people
excellent so
as you look around this is the area of
analysis
you will see that this table represents
a number of different technologies that
generate data
and so you will see next generation
sequencing data
mass spectroscopy data structural
biology data
and then here you will see a number of
additional sections for
downstream analysis and application to a
particular type of data for example
in virology you will see this right here
so
in next generation sequencing data on
this side
for those of you that have a demo
account
login you will be able to follow along
using some of these demo pipelines for
those of you that have
a full account you will also later be
introduced
to how to upload your own data or a data
set from
a public repository and run these
pipelines
but just to kind of give you a sense of
what this is
let's take a look over here under
phylogenetic tree
okay and we'll take a look at this first
example
okay so here in the first example
again i'll go back and i will i open
this drop down
right so phylogenetic tree you can see
that the drop down opens this up and i'm
going to go to phylogenetic
analysis
okay and then once you're in here you'll
be able to
click on these buttons and essentially
create a pipeline right and so
what is a pipeline a pipeline is
something that connects multiple steps
into a sequence of scripts so each
button here represents a script
and once you have created that script
it has been added to your pipeline
and this pipeline now could be executed
okay so this is just an example pipeline
you can see that the next step opens up
after you have completed the previous
step
okay so now i've run my pipeline
and this means that it is loading okay
so as you can see these are
different types of sections that deal
with
transcriptomic data analysis deal with
mutation variant analysis that deal with
different types of metagenomic data
analysis
amplicon data analysis and so you will
see how in the context of this full
program
we will use a lot of these different
sections to understand
how they are applied in the context of
specific questions
research questions that you have so how
do you use the appropriate method
for answering that question now i'm not
going to
necessarily go into this right now but
let me give you an overview
of what are some of these methods of
analysis
so that we understand what they do
so the first obvious one we kind of saw
that pop up there already
is alignment right so we take multiple
assembled sequences this is once we have
fasta files
and we compare them to each other to
identify
regions that are dissimilar so here for
example you have
gs everywhere apart from this section
that has t's now this is at the
nucleotide level
and one of the questions that you
typically would ask
is what is the impact of this particular
mutation
on the amino acid sequence because that
determines
determines function and that determines
protein structure
and so we'll learn about different types
of mutations and how those mutations
affect this amino acid sequence
as well as the codon structure in the
dna so that we can understand
what are the specific biases or typical
expected rates of mutation for example
in viruses in different codons
another example is when we deal with
fastq
files so when we deal with fastq files
the
actual reads in the dataset that we have
they actually represent uh
multiple variations that could be uh
common so they could be aligned between
multiple reads that have been sequenced
for example like here you have
the reference genome and in the
reference genome we have a t
and then in our reads we find one two
three
four five evidences for
a change in that position now sometimes
that change
is not as clear-cut here we have g and a
and here we have a c
so the question is what is this
substitution
right is this a technical error is this
a real substitution
what is it and sometimes we also see
evidence of
insertions and deletions that could be a
single nucleotide or multiple
nucleotides
and so really the way to deal with such
data is to run what's called
variant calling and so in the variant
calling analysis
what we are looking for is not
differences between
different assembled sequences
we are going to look for variance and
those variants
are defined by a
consensus between the reads that
that is higher than the threshold of
technical variation that we expect
as a result of technical issues with
sequencing
accuracy so when we look at
such data we want to identify
where could such variation come from for
example
selective pressures like antibacterial
drugs
antiviral drugs immune responses
we can also ask the question about what
are they associated with
right we had a question before how do we
identify
a relationship or an association between
genotype
and phenotype we can talk about
how variants can play a role in
the structure for example it directly
affects the amino acid sequence
and maybe the chemical property of the
change
is a va is changing or
maybe it is in a regulatory sequence
like the promoter region
and even though it doesn't affect the
exon it doesn't affect the protein
it still affects how it is expressed how
it is translated
and we can do what's called comparative
analysis so we can ask the question
if i have all of my uh all of my
variants for many samples how could i
divide them up into different groups and
compare them and maybe extract
the differential variance that i observe
in my data
so let's take a look at an example let's
say we have
replication so we have a virus
it's a pathogen the pathogen enters the
cell
inside the cell it replicates there is
an immune response
okay so one of the things that we can
ask is if i know the sequence of the
virus that
entered the cell how can i study what
came
out of the cell and so when we look at
this biological scenario
we can start asking the question what
are the differences
in the genomic sequences or maybe even
more interestingly
how can we find many different results
as a result of many different pathogens
living together in a single cell
and then we actually observe a
variety as a result of the different
selective pressures and so the obvious
question if you extrapolate this
biological question
to many organisms across a process of
time
is to start reconstructing not only what
are the specific sequences
but also how do they correlate to each
other
how could we organize this into some
kind of a biological model
essentially that is represented by the
data that we collect
and the data that we collect are the
genomic sequences of individual
genomes or viruses of bacteria etc
so phylogenetic tree reconstruction
first of all has
many different methods and two it could
be done
uh either by looking at the molecular
clock
or essentially what is the rate of
mutations that are accumulating across
the whole genome
or how do we maybe link it to real time
if we have real-time metadata we could
start finding associations between
molecular clock which is produced
computationally
and the real observation data which we
know from collecting different samples
and so in the context of this program
what we'll look at is
how are these trees generated so you're
probably familiar with
examples like this this is the source
cove oh this is the ebola virus
outbreak and you can see here how it
separates into multiple clades
representing
evolution adaptation to the host because
it originated from a different host
common origin how maybe there was a
particular event
that caused these the split into
different uh
clades and what is the price of
divergence so ultimately
you can see that only specific ones
were the most successful at surviving
for a longer time
and so these examples are going to be
used as
case studies these case studies will
introduce you to the biological
kind of background will give you a sense
of what are the types of research
questions that we are going to
ask and then how do we organize our
bioinformatics analysis to answer those
questions
with the specific discovery and
with validation so where are we getting
these projects
these projects are taken from the public
domain again they're taking from
peer-reviewed
publications that typically include the
data so they describe
how the data was generated why it was
generated who generated it right all the
questions that we need to know about
data
what are the methods that they used to
analyze such data
and once you get a sense of how experts
and people that have spent
considerable time researching these data
sets you can
essentially start taking either the same
data or
combine it with other types of data
and the same methods or new methods that
you have learned
and develop what's called a project of
your own and the idea here is to first
of all focus on
projects that are novel and independent
but within the context of particular
examples
that we have covered in these sessions
now some of these examples include
things like
some of these examples include
things like the novel coronavirus so
again these are
projects beeps if you could put the link
to the projects
for people to take a look at that where
we essentially take
some of the some of the data sets
that were used to kind of ask the
question about
origin we look at how
the different strains from bats
from pangolin from stars cove 2 were
compared to each other
we looked at how those helped identify
most dissimilar regions and what were
some of the conclusions about the
origin we also looked at how that
was translated to an understanding of
the 3d structure
impacts right so how could this be an
evidence
for example for adaptation between
different species
right so essentially what we will do is
we will take a look at
divergence at the genomic level we will
also take a look at
structural components right and
what important what is important is
we'll try to
piece this information together with
available structures of proteins right
so for example you've probably all heard
about the h2 receptor so we'll take a
look at the model
of the h2 receptor how it's actually a
complex
and the complex includes the bo at1
sodium-dependent neutral amino acid
transport transporter
and that's where we will apply
some computational magic to align
known structures to each other and
understand
how does the virus actually bind to this
complex and how
what does it actually do so we'll take a
look at
these examples and kind of identify
the important functional domains in
these
proteins that we all heard about and we
all hear people talk about all the time
so
that's one example uh obviously we have
a whole project on the evolution of
ebola virus
and how such analysis could be
replicated
again the phylogenetic tree is just one
visual that people use but there's a lot
more questions that you could
specifically ask for example
what are some of the haplotypes right so
how could we identify
differences between strains that are
more
effective at replicating or less
effective at replicating
by comparing them not in terms of
individual variants
but in terms of their comp composition
right so here you can see
more haplotype diversity here you can
see less haplotype diversity
and in fact we will also follow through
some literature review
where these types of issues were
highlighted right so we're not proposing
something completely new but we're
actually linking it back
to some of the research that already
validated some of these same findings
now importantly we'll look at other
hypotheses that were proposed
during those outbreaks right where
people said
we're so concerned with airborne
transmission for example right
or a particular mutation can have such
an impact or another kind of impact
today kind of looking back it's much
easier to take a look at this data
look at the specific mutations that have
come up
in the data and try to see whether
that's the direction to continue
research
or where where does that lead us
now another example that we'll use is in
tuberculosis
as an example of drug resistance so
tuberculosis has
single drug resistance multiple drug
resistance and this is a common issue
in many different pathogens so we've
kind of
assembled a number of examples from
these different types of
data sets viral data sets uh
bacterial data sets parasites like
malaria so we'll introduce you to those
data sets in our next
session we'll take a look at different
sequencing technologies so
really to understand what is the data
that we're dealing with
now what we want from you today
is to start thinking about a project of
your own now
many of you are researchers many of you
are working perhaps on your phd or
already doing some research work so what
we want to know
early on is what are the specifics about
your research question uh biebs if you
could post the link
to uh this on the forum so again
this is primarily for those that have
already completed your registration
and i'll just show you how to find this
form where you can submit this
information
so again this is for those of you that
have already registered
uh if you go to the same
educational portal as we were on before
where we looked at the introduction to
bioinformatics course
i will show you how there is a specific
dedicated
area for all of you that are part of the
group so
what where you should go is under events
there's a list of programs and so the
program
here that we're talking about is
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
now gucci
so you click on here under programs
and you will find the information
specifically about the program
found right here and here you will find
different types of updates
so for example you can see that beeps
have posted here a number of videos
that we have done already in the free
webinars related to this program
and you will also find different types
of activity from different participants
of the program
but what we are talking about right now
is this section on the forum
so here on the forum you can ask
questions
you can ask uh you know if there was
trouble with something you can post it
here
uh there are some resources here and an
important part here is the project
submission form
so the project submission form is
essentially there to help you structure
your ideas about your research topic
into an organized form that we will
review
and one of our mentors either harpreed
or muhit will reach out to you
to make sure that we address all of the
different parts of this
submission of this proposal so here you
will find
project title the problem statement
what exactly are you trying to do and
why the project summary where was the
data
what is the data how many samples do you
have what kind of analysis
are you proposing to do links to the raw
data so we can check
whether the data could be used to answer
your research question
and any reference reference publication
so we know that you've done your
literature review
so the main thing here is to really help
you organize your information in such a
way that an external reviewer can take a
look
evaluate and provide you with some
feedback on what you're trying to do
okay so let me briefly summarize what
are the important program resources
that you should be getting access to and
again
any questions about these resources you
should be
asking from bipsa so she's the community
manager
she will give you your login information
if you don't have it uh she will guide
you to where
to complete your registration right so
if you don't know
this program registration how to finish
your registration
reach out to her it's marketing and find
out bio
if you don't know where to find a
particular project that i showed
i've shown you resources from everything
that's already available so you can ask
her
again we'll take a look at all of these
different things
but if you have any questions reach out
to her now as i mentioned
omixlogic is not just about
training it's not just theoretical
training it's just not you know
acquiring skills
it is really a community and so what's
important is
as you're getting started with these
different resources we're asking you to
complete your profile
and when you complete your profile
you're not doing it for us you're doing
it for yourself
we want other people to be able to find
you in the program
list and know that this person is from
this university or this lab that's what
they're doing maybe that's their social
media profile right
we hope that you can connect to each
other because ultimately
in any bioinformatics research project
there's going to be collaboration and a
collaboration
is a big part of what we are trying to
help you establish here as well
there are many international researchers
students
and faculty from many different
universities so we're really hoping that
you could connect
now the basic tools that we already
talked about
are the server account where you can run
big data analysis and courses
these are practical courses if you're
not familiar with the basics
how to do alignment what types of
mutations to expect
what are variations in gene expression
those are the types of questions that
are going to be covered in these
courses they will provide you also with
quizzes that you can answer to know that
you have understood the material
you can answer those questions they will
also provide you with
assignments those practical assignments
will most likely use the server
analytical platform
to show you how this analysis is done
and make sure that you can submit your
assignments
to get feedback on this pro
on this program page so on this program
page you will find
the resources specifically around
this group of people this program so
here you will find
things like the forum and the courses
that are included there
different project examples that we have
discussed
and you will also see how you can track
your activity so let me show you
what that actually looks like okay and
thank you beeps that has posted the link
okay so here you have this menu
in this menu you can find the courses
and these are courses that are included
in this
program right so if you have not
completed the registration
you have to complete the registration
first before you have access to this
uh so genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics etc so you will find some
of these courses right here
there are also a number of project
examples so these project
examples are going to introduce you to
some case studies
and those case studies are going to help
you understand how it was done in the
context of a particular research
question now a lot of these
might not necessarily be related to
viruses or bacteria or anything like
that but they will
illustrate how such analysis could be
used
okay what is inside these courses
inside these courses we explain the
rationale
and objective why are we learning about
a particular data type
and what is the terminology and the
biological context
you will see engaging activities that
will help link
the specific topics and concepts to
what you are going to do so that the
analysis you do
is based on logic then we're going to
include a data set
or a project with an explanation of
where it came from and what is this data
and you will understand what are some
databases research publications and
project examples as well as file
formats then you will run an analysis
pipeline
and that will help you establish the
logic of how these different steps are
connected into a single workflow
and you will be able to see some
examples of outputs that you need to
look through to understand what was in
the data
and finally it will provide you with a
point system
so that you can compare your progress to
the overall progress of the group so one
of the important things that we
have found is that consistency
and returning to the assignments
regularly helps you understand and
become
more proficient so i'll just show you
what that looks like
for example you can look through
you can look through some of these
example profiles i will just show you
uh you know what a profile of a typical
participant would look like and i see
that somebody has already completed
their profile
jeff so let's take a look at jeff's
profile
sorry jeff for putting you on the spot
here but
hopefully others can learn from your
experience already
so jeff has joined and you can see that
he has
300 points right and so those points are
from
completing the profile registering on
the platform
and now you can see what courses he is
taking now i'm not going to show you
everything because
things like quiz results and assignments
are going to be proprietary to his
that's his progress but you can still
kind of get a sense of
what he's doing so he's enrolled in a
number of these courses
and as he continues to build up his
profile you will start seeing
progress in those courses now here are
some
of the top profiles you can see
we have a leaderboard of the top 100
participants
from all over the world you will see
that they are from many different
regions in the world
and really anyone can start with this
process for free essentially and with
minimal basic subscription you can get
started so you can see here
different people that have a number of
points and the change in those points
and you will see all the way to
the last person in this list
and that's about 14 000 points right so
if you want to be on this list
we'll feature you once you get to this
list once you get essentially over 10
000 points we will feature you
but you can take a look at some of these
examples and what these people have been
able to do
through the course of this program okay
so let me pause
and see if there are any questions
and beeps if you could please launch or
never mind i can launch i think this
second poll
so we have another poll uh this is on
feedback so i'm going to ask
uh for you to be um very honest
uh so we are looking to improve these
sessions and make sure that the sessions
are informative
and useful for what you're trying to do
so the first question is how would you
rate the session
i will not be offended so you can uh
you know tell me that was uh very poor
if you did not like it
um the second question is what did you
like
the best about the session so if you
like how the topic was presented
or it was specifically related to
infectious disease research
and if you didn't learn anything new
that's also fine we would like to know
and then the question number three is
what is your expectation
from the program so if you would like to
learn about new bioinformatics tools
or you want to get introduced to
virology research or gain basic
understanding of bioinformatics if
you're just getting started
so those are some of the questions
please try to answer these questions
in the poll itself and i'm going to
leave this on here for
a few more minutes for anyone to be able
to
look through and also if you have any
questions
right so i'm here to try and answer any
of the questions that you have
and after the questions i will
introduce you to one other resource that
i think you will find
interesting and relevant to what we're
going to do and give you an assignment
for our next time
as the feedback is going on we have a
question here from
ahmad kevari regarding the pipeline
how to note down the procedure in the
methods
section of publication i'm not quite
sure if that refers
to the pipeline okay so as i understand
the question
is let's say you've used the pipeline to
analyze your data
and you want to report how you've
generated
that data so one of the useful things
i'll just give you an example with my
pipeline
i used a pipeline
for mapping data from waste water
treatments
to identify stars growth ii and
this is a part of a publication so i'm
going to report on it
so the good thing is that first of all i
have a reproducible workflow so these
are the individual methods
i used bowtie to align and then pause
count and names replace
and i will find a report on this
pipeline
right here so each pipeline has a report
so
in that report i will see which version
of the
method was used what was the input data
what was the output data and how
long did it take for this to run and you
also referenced the t bioinfo platform
which was developed at the tower
bioinformatics research center
so here you can use that as a reference
for
running it on this server
okay so the question from francis
can the project be a systematic review
in the field of bioinformatics
uh yes so again a systematic review in
the field
the field of bioinformatics i would say
is humongous it has been around for
decades there are many different tools
databases and applications of
bioinformatics
and i would say that you know you can
definitely attempt
an overview a systematic review of
bioinformatics but i would
rather recommend a focused approach
so if you first of all learn about the
general applications of bioinformatics
through the introduction to
bioinformatics course
there you will see different types of
methods applications
databases data types etc so once you
have
done that you can also focus
for example on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases right
and there you can do some systematic
review
right so i think it depends on really
what is your primary objective
and your focus and since you're already
a registered participant in the program
i think we'll be able to develop that
idea further
after a few more sessions
beeps do we have results uh on the uh
poll
yes we do have uh results on the poll
and i see that there are still uh
participants who are still voting okay
let's go let's answer a couple of these
questions
hold on let's just wait on until we have
how many percent overall have answered
we have uh 58 percent who have voted so
we can wait for a few more
okay thanks okay so let's take a look at
these questions how do i apply
bioinformatics in plant breeding
research
i think that's a good question obviously
genotyping right so looking at
established mutations in particular
genes
could be very useful but if we talk
about the
infectious diseases there are many
infectious diseases that are
specifically for uh uh
or sorry yeah plant breeding right so
there they are viruses that affect for
example different plants
there are microbes that are used as
fertilizers
we we had a session uh yesterday
on metagenomics where we talk about the
application of microbiome studies in
different domains
including agriculture so i think that
there are
a lot of applications and one of the
projects that we have
you can start looking at it right here
under projects
if you go to all of the projects
or actually right here on the very top
you can see crop drought stress and
resistance
so this is a transcriptomic study
right here and that transcriptomic study
helps you understand
differences between drought resistant
and less resistant strains of potato
cultivars
okay another question good afternoon can
be possible to
feel the virology be able to grow the
interest and grow the fuel
yes so this program is specifically
designed for people that
you know are not technically maybe uh
versed in bioinformatics uh so if you're
already in the field of virology
uh maybe beeps say you could post a link
on how to complete the registration
to this program on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
this would be a great start for you
learning about bioinformatics and trying
to apply it to
your particular area of research
we have another question from jeff
so jeff's question is as we are thinking
of the project is it advisable to come
up with a project on clinical trials
well i think the main question about
clinical trials is availability of data
can you actually get access to raw data
to do the analysis because a lot of
clinical trials
will only report data after they have
completed
okay i'm a bioinfo student but i don't
have money to afford it but i have
willingness to learn and explore is
there any aid or free resources
yes first of all there are many free
resources please join for free
and you have access to a number of
introductory courses for free and i'll
introduce you in a second here to our
coding platform
where you can also practice some of the
coding and see how these things are
applied
in the context of r and python
but we also have an assistance program a
scholarship program
intended specifically for people that
have financial needs
beeps if you could paste the link to our
scholarship request form
excellent thank you okay so let's take a
look at the poll results if we can uh
beeps
yes okay so as for the first question
how would you rate this session
so we see that 59 percent of our
participants have
said that they found the session very
informative 22 percent said that they
found the section
excellent while 14 percent to give it a
good
which is a three and five person says it
was okay
moving on to the second question what
did you like best about the session
51 person says that i like how the topic
was presented
27 percent says that the session
introduced
them to infectious diseases research and
22 person said that
they're already familiar with the topic
and the session had to add to their
knowledge and regarding the third
question which is what is your
expectation from the program
57 percent of the participants want to
learn about new bioinformatics tools
while the next 30 person wants to learn
or gain
basic understanding of bioinformatics
and
14 person wants to get introduced to
biology research
so that's the poll er
all right thank you very much so thank
you for the feedback those of you that
did not like the session
really did not have to come you know i'm
just joking so um
hopefully next session is going to be
more informative i will try to improve
if you send me some specific
recommendations or how
on how we can do this better we would be
very glad to
look through and address your comments
so briefly
let me now actually introduce you to the
last resource on the list
if you could go with me to
code.omicslogic.com
so a big part of what we do
is going to be based on big data
analysis and one of the challenges in
big data analysis is
infrastructure another challenge is
coding proficiency
to deal with data okay thank you uh
beeps for posting the link you can also
register here for free
so please let me know once you're here
and you have registered now for those of
you that are part of the omixlogic
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
at university of ghana you should use
the exact same email address
as you are using for your registration
okay please let me know once you have
registered and i should
get here a notification if you are
registering
so uh please go to this link
and let me know once you are in
and once you're in what you should see
is
this list of courses and i'll kind of go
through
and give you uh just a very brief
example of what we will be doing during
the program
okay so let me know if you have
registered
if you're already registered just maybe
put yes i'm there
in the chat box so i know that you're
there
all right thank you francis anyone else
all right excellent
okay i'll wait for a couple more minutes
for everybody to get here
what this is is a collection of
similar topics that are explained
more at the script level so
you will see here um simple courses like
getting started for example where you
can
load data and visualize it and maybe
read dna sequences in r
and one of the things that we would like
to ask you to do if you have completed
your registration
is to take a look at this course called
genomics so some of the things that we
are going to be doing
in the context of this program is
looking at
variance and looking at structure and
things like that
so i'm going to go through this brief
lesson to just kind of explain how
this works you'll learn here about dna
structure
what are the mutations and things like
that you'll also learn
that dna is organized into chromosomes
and
what does that mean in terms of
different variants
and where they are in the codons and
it will be followed by a quiz
so here you'll learn some theoretical
things and you can know that this is a
theoretical lesson
if it has this learn tag right here
but then you want to practice how does
this actually
uh work in r for example so here
when you get to this stage you'll see
how
for example we can assign specific
strings of characters to
a uh an object right
and you can for example print that
object now
sometimes you want to compare those
sequences
and here we go through an explanation of
pairwise
alignment first okay and and here's an
example
so how does this work here you are
loading a specific library
and you're putting in some strings in
here and then
you have to click on run and it will
actually run right here in the browser
so after you click the run button it
will provide you
with the result and you can see that you
have here success this code has been run
successfully
so as you go through these exercises
they will become a little bit more and
more advanced
as you go through so once you go through
you complete you go to the next one
that is a little bit more challenging
for example
let's go to the next one okay here we're
dealing with multiple sequences so here
we have three
different sequences okay let's try to
run this
just as an example
okay so now instead of just the output
you also have this link round right here
down at the bottom
actually shows you the sequence and
shows you where the difference is
okay so these types of activities
are also connected to your profile and
you will see
under your profile that these activities
are going to add points to your overall
progress
okay so the link to registration this is
the link to register to this particular
coding
playground what we call coding
playground but also
um if beep say you could send a link to
the registration for the program okay
so as you go through you will then find
a challenge
so here you see final assignment here
you're given a
specific situation you have metabolism
of drugs
and your goal is to identify which
mutation
is going to cause problems for
metabolism of drugs
okay so here you'll see that you
actually have to
write your own code and figure it out
right so in such a way we hope that
you'll be able to
practice some of the code understand how
this code is applied
to a particular problem statement and
then
practice your coding so that you learn
how to do it on your own
so again the goal of this program is to
introduce you
to a lot of the areas of bioinformatics
like the tools for big data analysis
where you will run pipelines and
understand how they're
operating as well as practice different
types of analysis in
r and in python including some of the
things that we
just looked at and i hope that most of
you will be
taking the time after this session to
complete your profile
and make sure that we're getting started
with this program
ready for your research
project so this is the assignment for
our next session
complete your educational profile on the
tea bioinfo
two take the free course introduction to
bioinformatics and fill out that survey
we want to know more about you about
your research interest
and three familiarize yourself with the
tbi info server
and the codomix logic playground so
those are the last two resources that we
just had
and to remind you this program starting
today
january 29th will go through
sequence variation and alignment
evolutionary and phylogenetic analysis
functionality and protein structure
including the physical chemical
properties of proteins
and transcriptomic analysis of host
response
again thank you everyone for joining
today we went a little bit
over our time but i will pass it on to
beeps that kind of take over and answer
any technical questions
unfortunately i have another meeting to
go to but for those of you that like
this session
i thank you for your feedback those of
you that
did not like the session i am looking
forward to your specific feedback what
you think should be improved
and you can email me directly by going
by emailing elia at pine.bio
and i'm going to look forward to
learning from you as well
website over to you yeah thank you so
much helia so i will quickly start by
sharing my screen
so for any of you who are having
problems with logging into
code.omicslogic
when you go to the site for the first
time right now
i am logged in you will notice a get
started button
you do not need to use the password that
you have for edut bio info or the tb
info
server you need to create a new login it
will send a password reset link to your
email and from then
on you would not need any password to
log into the site it will register your
email
id so please try that post the session
so that we are able to help you with
this
if you face any kind of problems with
this
login and please note that your edutbio
info login is separate from your
tbio info login which is the server
platform
but one thing is similar for all of
these three platforms which is your
email
id so please make sure that you're
utilizing the same
email id the edut buyer info
the t buyer info and the omix logic code
platform should have the same email
id